Revolution ist nicht eine Sache von Tagen, wo geschossen wird und Auseinandersetzung stattfindet. Revolution ist ein langer, lang andauernder Marsch und Prozess, um die Schaffung von neuen Menschen, die fähig sind, nicht eine Clique durch eine andere zu ersetzen nach der Revolution, sondern massenhaft Demokratisierung von unten, bewusste Produzentendemokratie entgegenzusetzen, bürokratische Herrschaft von oben. An diesem Kampf habt ihr weiter zu arbeiten, in diesem Kampf habt ihr eure Bedürfnisse zu entfalten und in diesem Kampf ist jeder beteiligt, wo er auch immer sich in dieser Welt befinden mag.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 77. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch am 17. Februar 2008 zu einer neuen Ausgabe vom Express. Und immer noch bin ich auf meiner Podcastreise in Hamburg, die dritte und wie es aussieht letzte Haltestelle, bevor es dann wieder zurück nach Berlin geht. Und ja, für diese Ausgabe habe ich eine ganz besondere Runde zusammengerufen, die auf eine ganz besondere Art und Weise mit der Geschichte des Chaos Computer Clubs verwoben ist. Ich würde es jetzt mal die Tuwat-Runde bezeichnen. Darauf werden wir dann jetzt im weiteren noch eingehen, aber ich will jetzt erstmal vorstellen, wen ich hier eigentlich um mich herum habe. Von links nach rechts begrüße ich Wolf Gevert, eingefleischter Hamburger, wie ich gerade erfahren habe. Das gilt aber glaube ich auch für alle Beteiligten, ich weiß es nicht genau. Dann Klaus Schleisiek, auch mit am Apparat. Auch als Tom Tüdelwit bekannt. Damit haben wir ja schon ein wichtiges Recherche-Stichwort für den Google herausgegeben. Und last but not least, Jochen Büttner auf meiner rechten Seite. Ihr drei seid ja alle schon vor langer langer Zeit mit Technologie in Berührung gekommen. Wie sehr, das werden wir sicherlich gleich noch mal hören. Und um es schon mal vorweg zu nehmen, ihr wart alle dabei bei dem Vorbereitungstreffen für ein anderes Treffen, das unter dem Namen Tuwat.Txt oder auch einfach nur Tuwat bekannt geworden ist, über eine Annonce in der Tageszeitung, die dann zu einem Treffen geführt hat am 12. September 1981, was wir so beim Chaos Computer Club ein wenig als die Gründungsstunde des Clubs verstehen. Ich wollte jetzt hier mal ein wenig auf die Hintergründe und die Vorgeschichte dieser Zeit zu sprechen kommen, um einfach mal ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was eigentlich euch dazu gebracht hat, dieses Treffen einzubehufen. Ja, aber vielleicht kann man noch mal kurz so ein bisschen zu euch erstmal was einführen. Wolf Gevert, du bist, ja Hamburger, das hatten wir schon, eingefleischt. Und was ist denn so deine Begegnung mit Technologie und sozusagen was ist so der Grund dafür, dass du letzten Endes in dieser Planungsrunde gelandet bist?
Ja, ich war ja Anfang der 80er-Jahre schon ziemlich lange in der EDV, das heißt, Ende der 50er-Jahre bin ich Programmierer geworden. Ja, Mitte der 60er-Jahre habe ich mich dann selbstständig gemacht und das war eigentlich immer auch sehr abenteuerlich die ganze Zeit, die Pionierzeit.
Ja, also in den 50er-Jahren Programmierer zu werden.
Ja, das wusste auch kein Mensch, dass es sowas gibt. Im letzten Hamburger Adressbuch, was ist ja auch schon lange nicht mehr gibt, stehe ich drin noch als Drog. Weil offenbar der Setzer gedacht hat, das muss ein Schreibfehler sein.
Drog?
Ja, statt Proc.
Proc.
Ach so.
Programmierer könnte ich sagen.
Ja, ist das letzte Adressbuch.
Was hast du denn da programmiert?
Ja, das war zunächst ganz normale kommerzielle Programmierung für größere Unternehmen.
Und für größere Computer vor allem.
Ja, es gab damals ja nur große.
Also große IBM-Systeme.
Ja, die erste Generation war noch. Also ich war damals bei der Firma Remington angefangen. Also die haben nicht nur Knarn gebaut, sondern auch Rasierer. Die haben auch Computer gebaut.
Ach so.
Und hatten auch Tradition damit. Sie waren also immer ein Schritt vor der IBM gewesen damals. Also der erste Elektronenrechner, der ENIAC, der war Eckhardt und Moschli, das waren die beiden Ingenieure, die in den 40er Jahren haben, die schon fast gleichzeitig mit unserem lieben Zuse, der ja den ersten Programm gesteuerten Rechner, das war ein Relais-Rechner. Also damals kamen dann die ersten Rechner in die Betriebe, Lochkarte natürlich. Kein Mensch hatte vorher eine Lochkarte gesehen. Die kamen erst in den 50er Jahren, gab es die. Gab auch noch den Lochstreifen. Also Programme lagen vielfach auf Lochstreifen. Während die Daten, da musste man ja flexibel sein, die konnte man ja dann umlegen, das waren dann die Lochkarten.
Oh, ich sehe hier schon ein Thema für einen kommenden Chaosradio Express-Aufkommen, das Vintage-Computern der 50er Jahre.
Und das waren natürlich Anlagen, die richtig Geld kosteten. Ich weiß, also die erste Anlage, für die ich gearbeitet hatte, das war hier für unseren kommunalen Gasversorger. Das war, ja, das muss noch 59 oder so gewesen sein. Ich glaube, der kostete 50.000 Mark Miete jeden Monat. Und das waren so die Preiskarten. Und das war viel Geld damals. Ich weiß nicht, was ein Arbeiter verdient, aber ich schätze mal vielleicht so zwei Mark die Stunde. Also könnte er ungefähr hinkommen. Meine ich mich so.
Kann gut sein, weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Jedenfalls war das ein irrsinniges Geld. Aber ich bin dann nur einige Jahre dort geblieben, dann habe ich mich ja selbstständig gemacht, weil es war irgendwie, das hat mir nicht so recht gefallen, da diese totale Abhängigkeit. Der Vertrieb dieser Geräte wurde sehr honoriert. Also da gab es wirklich Leute, die solche Gehaltsabrechnungen bekamen, dass die EDV das nicht brachte, weil die Anzahl der Stellen einfach nicht mehr stimmte. Ich weiß zum Beispiel von einem Kollegen, das wurde viele Jahre kolportiert, da kam die Kirchensteuer nicht raus, obwohl das nur 8 Prozent von der Lohnsteuer war. Damals. Und lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Ja, viel Arbeit, 70 Überstunden die Woche hat es gegeben. Da war ich mit 70, da waren welche, die waren noch besser. Natürlich totale Scheiße, so was. Und dann bin ich zusammengebrochen, da war ich 27. Und da hat mich dann der Arzt 6 Wochen aus dem Verkehr gezogen, hat gesagt, wenn du einen Tag eher wiederkommst, brauchst du dich hier nicht wieder blicken zu lassen. Du bist eigentlich nicht ein Fall für einen Arzt, jedenfalls nicht für einen normalen praktischen Hausarzt. Naja, jedenfalls dann, wie gesagt, selbstständig. Und mein ganzes Leben dann bis in die 90er Jahre, also fast 30 Jahre lang. Das war ja die Zeit, wo ich dann Klaus auch kennenlernte. Das war dann in den 80er Jahren, aber erst vorher tronte ich da überall rum, in Berlin bei der chemischen Fabrik Tempelhof, CFT oder so, weiß nicht, ob es sie überhaupt noch gibt. Das war ein Pharmagroßhandel, der die Apotheken belieferte. Dann in Köln eine ganze Weile gesessen, auf Morgude Ports, da war Stollwerk damals noch. Auf den Toiletten hatten die doch tatsächlich goldene Wasserhähne, zwar nicht massiv gold, aber vergoldet, also in den Büros, das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Genau das war die Zeit, dann habe ich lange Zeit auch in Bremen gearbeitet, auf der Hütte, da war ja noch mal eine Hütte, Klöcknerhütte gibt es inzwischen wohl auch nicht mehr. Und dann lange Zeit auch in Frankfurt, da habe ich dann also für meinen alten Arbeitgeber gearbeitet. Der hatte dann schon zweimal seinen Namen geändert, also Remington kannte schon keiner mehr.
Ja, also einen besonderen Fußabtritt haben sie nicht gerade hinterlassen in der Computergeschichte.
Doch, also wenn du tiefer steigst und jetzt nicht oberflächlich Internet machst, das ist ja immer die Gefahr beim Internet, dass du da oben schwebst und du da nicht einfach tiefer kommst, weil du gar nicht weißt, warum mache ich jetzt weiter, um da reinzukommen. Doch, die Univac, die hießen nachher Univac, jetzt ist es leiser geworden. Die Univac-Rechner, die waren schon was. Also das waren die größten Rechner, die hier auf dem Markt waren. Die Flugsicherung zum Beispiel, die sitzt in Frankfurt, die hatten ein Doppelsystem. Dann, was weiß ich, Quelle und auch irgendwelche Geheimdienste, das durften wir aber auch nicht wissen. Irgendwo bei Köln war das, beziehungsweise bei Bonn.
Der Universal Automatic Calculator, da gibt es jetzt auch ein Modell, glaube ich, im Deutschen Museum in München, noch zu bestaunen.
Ganz sicher.
Das ist mittlerweile eingefleischte Computergeschichte. Das heißt, du hast dich über die ganze Zeit im Wesentlichen wirklich als Techniker, als Programmierer...
Nur als Programmierer.
Nur als Programmierer verdingt. Und hast du dann sozusagen dem Computer frühzeitig schon so... Hast du irgendwie im Geringsten die Erwartung, dass Computer mal so eine Verbreitung finden würden?
Ich hatte also schon das Gefühl, dass ich ein Programmier in einer Sache zu sein, die gerade kam. Dass es nun solche Ausmaße haben würde, insbesondere, dass der Computer nachher mal der toten Gräber der Arbeit werden würde. Also das habe ich natürlich nicht geahnt. Aber das habe ich natürlich dann in den 90er Jahren, war mir das schon klar, da habe ich mich auch völlig zurückgezogen. Und meine Frau hatte schon Anfang der 80er, ja, genau diese Zeit hier, 1983, hat die einen Bioladen aufgemacht. Und dann bin ich da mit eingestiegen. Wir haben jetzt im März 25-jähriges Jubiläum. Ja, das gibt es tatsächlich noch.
Es gibt doch 25-jährige Jubiläen. Ich habe gerade festgestellt, dass ich vor 25 Jahren mal angefangen habe mit dem Kram, das du aufgehört hast sozusagen.
Und mir hat natürlich diese normale kommerzielle Programmierung nicht unbedingt immer Spaß gemacht. Ich habe mich dann, ich habe immer gebastelt auch. Also Treiber geschrieben und solche Sachen. Also auch auf den großen Rechnern konnte man das machen.
Gab es da schon den Begriff Hacker?
Ich meine, der kann erst in den 80er Jahren aufgekommen sein. In den 70er Jahren hatten wir den bestimmt noch nicht. Das war die Zeit, als ich Wau kennenlernte.
Wo hast du den kennengelernt?
Also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich ihn auf einer Demo kennengelernt habe, weil er so sehr auffällig war. Er hatte immer ein Fahrrad bei sich, und zwar eins, das man zusammenklappen konnte. Das hat mich sehr beeindruckt. Ein Klapprad. Ja, so ein englisches war das wahnsinnig teuer. Kennst du das auch noch? Du warst eben nie dabei, wenn ich das mal vermute. Das müsstest du noch kennen. Ja, jedenfalls, da ist mir Wau über den Weg gelaufen.
Wogegen habt ihr denn da demonstriert?
Also ganz bestimmt auch gegen Atomkraftwerke. Wir waren also garantiert, also Brockdorf war ja ein Muss hier in Hamburg.
Hörst du einen guten Ton, ne?
Ja, ich meine, da war ja auch jeder, der irgendwie beweglich war, war dann auch in Brockdorf. Ich war auch nicht auf allen drei, sondern nur auf den letzten beiden. Und was hatten wir? Krümel hatten wir zum Beispiel. Und dann gab es natürlich noch die zentralen Demos, wo mit Klaus zusammen waren in Bonn. Das war dann aber, das war in den 80ern dann, auf der, wie hieß die Wiese da? Hofgarten, ne?
Ja, ja, vor dem erzbischöflichen Palais, ne?
Ja, das muss ja aber auch Anfang der 80er wieder gewesen sein.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, worum es da ging überhaupt.
Das ist Notstandsgesetze, meine ich.
Nein, zu Notstandsgesetzen, da habe ich ja, das war ja meine erste Demo, da war ich aber noch Oberprimaler. Ja, das war eine politisierung.
Vielleicht kurz bevor wir noch zu Klaus kommen, noch mal kurz zu Wau, also Wau Holland muss man ja auch nochmal erwähnen, der irgendwie sehr prägend war für die erste Zeit des Chaos Computer Clubs, leider 2001 dann sehr plötzlich und unerwartet verstorben ist. Wie bist du dann an ihn gewartet?
Sogar der Spiegel hat ja einen Nachruf gebracht. Man kommt ja ins Gespräch auf so ein Thema und friert da ja nicht nur rum. Das hat ihn irgendwie interessiert, dass ich schon so lange in dieser Branche, aber für die er sich ja nun auch gerade zu erwärmen begann. Wir haben uns dann auch viel getroffen, da bei ihm am Eidlstellerweg. Da saß er da ja im Keller. Ich weiß aber auch nicht mehr genau, wann das war, aber das war alles in den 80er Jahren. Zwischendurch haben wir dann dieses Treffen hier gehabt. Das ist ja durch den Bildbruch von Klaus gekommen. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass Klaus eine ganz tragende Rolle bei der Sache gespielt hat. Wann kommst du denn da aus Amerika zurück?
Erzähl doch mal deine Geschichte.
Genau mit Tabs. Das war genau der Punkt, wo Wau dann absolut darauf abfuhr. Das sehe ich noch wie heute. Ich habe auch noch ein paar alte Tabs zu Hause.
Du auch? Nee, sie sind alle im Clubarchiv gelandet.
Ach so, ja da sind sie.
Naja, also auch so, wo ich so herkomme, statt mich mit Mädchen und Gleichaltrigen im Alter von 14 Jahren zu beschäftigen, hatte ich mich lieber an den Lötkolben und die Elektronen gehalten. Also die machten nicht so unvorher-sagbare Dinge. Und dann bin ich, wie gesagt, so als gerade noch 68er habe ich das mitgekriegt, habe ich so meinen Politisierungsschub gekriegt und bin in der Autonomen Jugendzentrumsbewegung in Mörs gelandet. Also ich bin kein Alt-Hamburger, sondern ich bin erst dann hierher gekommen. Das hat aber wieder viel mit den Brockdorf-Demos zu tun. Da ist nämlich Gegenöffentlichkeit hier entstanden in Hamburg und der Medienladen. Und da wurde ich als Techniker angeworben, um das Video-Equipment ans Laufen zu halten. Und dabei habe ich eben Jochen kennengelernt. Aber das war dann, das muss 75 gewesen sein. Da war es vollkommen klar, dass nun die Weltrevolution durch die japanische Erfindung Videofilme auf halb Zoll Magnetbandspulen herstellen zu können. War ganz klar, dass das das alles befördern würde. Und der Medienladen war dann so eine Ausleihstation, wo man also das Equipment holen konnte, wo man Flugblätter drucken konnte. Das war alles sehr bewegungsorientiert. Und außerdem gab es dann noch Kurse. Entstanden war das Ganze, aber kann Jochen auch mal was zu sagen. Das ist außer HFBK. Jedenfalls so bin ich hier in Hamburg gelandet. Und der Medienladen brach dann irgendwann an seinen inneren und äußeren Widersprüchen zusammen, wandelte sich in den Frauenmedienladen Bildwechsel um. Und dann hatte ich so mehr durch Zufalls als sonst was die Gelegenheit, in die USA zu gehen und dafür einen Soundkünstler, eine größere elektronische Soundinstallation zu machen. Und dieser USA-Ausmahl hat sich insgesamt drei Jahre hingezogen.
Was war denn das für eine Installation?
Im Dom für tropische Pflanzen in St.Paul in Minnesota wurden 64 Lautsprecher angebracht. Und jeder dieser Lautsprecher war an so einem, also wir sprechen hier von 1979, an so einem Pinball-Machine, Soundchip angeschlossen. Und da habe ich dann mit Lichtgriffel auf Videomonitor so eine interaktive Umgebung gebaut, damit man da irgendeinen Ton einstellen kann. Das war ein witziges Projekt. Ja, und dann saß ich da und war dann Anfang 1981 auf einmal stolzer Besitzer eines Osborne I. Und konnte jetzt selber mit dem Rechner arbeiten und meine ersten Texte bauen.
Das war ja der erste, naja Laptop will ich jetzt mal nicht sagen, aber so der erste wirklich portable Computer, der so halbwegs Furore gemacht hat. Ein großer wirtschaftlicher Erfolg war er glaube ich nicht. Aber so ein großer Kübel mit Griff zum Wegwerfen, mit Bildschirm drin. So ein großer Kübel ist übertrieben.
So eine Nähmaschinengröße. Ein Schleppdruck, genau. Ein Schleppable. Das gab es ja nicht nur das, sondern der war witzigerweise auch noch in einer Community entstanden. Entworfen von Lee Felsenstein, der in Berkeley saß und dort auch schon soziale Aspekte vom Rechner um experimentiert hat. Da entstand das Community Memory Project. Das Community Memory Project hat dann später die Zeitschrift Processed World rausgegeben, die eine sehr stark gewerkschaftlich orientierte Sicht auf diese elektronischen Arbeitsplätze, die es natürlich in San Francisco in der Bay Area massenweise gab, hatte und wahrscheinlich existiert die Processed World auch immer noch.
Community Memory war letztlich eine Computermailbox.
Nee, das waren mehrere PDP-Elven, vielleicht noch nicht PDP-Achten wahrscheinlich. Standen, glaube ich, an drei Standorten, waren überhand gezogene Kabel miteinander verbunden und es war ein öffentliches Billet-and-Board-System, also was man nicht zum Zustellen persönlicher Nachrichten brauchen konnte, sondern alles, was man da eingab, war öffentlich zugänglich in einer Baumstruktur. Und damit haben sie angefangen zu experimentieren und was so ganz unerwartet war, wie viel Lyrik dabei zustande gekommen ist.
Die Alvisen im Müllhalde meint dazu, dass es sich um SDS 940 Scientific Data Systems Computer gehandelt haben sollte. War wohl noch keine PDP am Start. Aber man konnte da theoretisch auch schon so von außen ran. Wann ist das überhaupt? 73? Ah, das klingt ja okay, denn das war noch keine.
Also das war schon voll in Betrieb, als ich da auftauchte. Ja, und damals habe ich auch erste Versuche in San Francisco mitgekriegt, ein öffentliches Mailbox-System zu bauen. Und zwar nach dem Prinzip, was dann später hier das Servos-Netz war. Und das war so meine erste Berührung mit der Szene. Und also mit diesen Erfahrungen und kennengelernten Sachen im Hinterkopf und einem Osborn 1 in der rechten Hand, tauchte ich dann also 1981 hier wieder in Hamburg auf und zog dann bei Jochen in die Eppendorfer Landstraße 16.
So war es. Und wie hielten den Kontakt seit dem Medienladen? Das war eine Gruppe, die sich damals eben aus der HWK heraus gefunden hatte. Und der Ansatz war, gegen Öffentlichkeit in irgendeiner Art und Weise auszuprobieren. Und Video und Film waren die tragenden Elemente. Und man hat versucht, natürlich bestimmte Sachen publizistisch zu begleiten. Also gab es Auflagen von alten Büchern, Reprint. Da hast du noch die Drogmaschinen und diese Sachen in Gang gehalten. Kein Raubdrog?
Gehört zum guten Ton, würde ich sagen.
Also stellte sich diese Alternative eben nicht, normale Bücher zu machen, sondern nur eben die anderen. Und aus dieser Geschichte heraus, denke ich, hat sich eine begleitende Art und Weise für mich ergeben, auch an diese Computer mit heranzukommen, obwohl ich hier nicht verhehlen möchte, dass ich das schon damals etwas kritisch sah. Und die Strafarbeiten entsprechend aufgebrumpt bekamen, nämlich Programme zu testen.
Ja, der Usability-Experte der Frühzeit.
Ja, mit für mich etwas frustrierendem Erfolg, weil ich es nicht begriffen habe, warum es bei mir nicht ging. Und das Giole der anderen war großartig, weil sie wussten, irgendwie was sie falsch gemacht haben. Aber dieser Ping-Pong-Effekt, der war etwas schwierig auszuhalten.
Aber das heißt ja, dieser Medienladen, von wem wurde das getragen?
Freie Initiative.
Das heißt, Leute haben sich einfach zusammengefunden, haben diesen Ort gemacht. Und Gegenöffentlichkeit hast du gesagt. Was war denn die Öffentlichkeit, die sozusagen da eine Gegenöffentlichkeit erforderte? Was muss man sich denn jetzt mal so, wenn man mal zurückblickt, von welchem Zeitraum, wann wurde der Medienladen eingerichtet?
Mitte der 70er Jahre.
Mitte der 70er Jahre. Über 30 Jahre her.
Also Hamburg. Das war doch hier Heimspiel für Springer und Co. Die haben ja nun wirklich eine Gegenöffentlichkeit herausgefordert. Das war ja wirklich ganz übel, was da teilweise hat.
Ist das jetzt schon so ein Resultat der 68er-Bewegung an der Stelle?
Nee, ich glaube, der Medienladen selber, den kann man noch anders zurückverfolgen. Das hat, glaube ich, ganz viel mit der Anti-AKW-Bewegung zu tun. Und mit Wiel, weil nach meinem...
Mit was? Mit Wiel.
Dreiecksland, ne?
Dreiecksland. Der erste Atomreaktor in der Bundesrepublik, der nicht gebaut wurde. Und da ist ja ganz entscheidend Schuld dran gewesen, ich glaube, Panorama war es. Es ging auf jeden Fall zu derz in den Anfangs-70ern über den Fernsehsender, dass Polizei auf ältere Menschen einprügelt. Und zwar so deutlich, dass man sah, das war wirklich vollkommen neben der Kapp die reine Willkür.
Und das lief im Fernsehen?
Das lief im Fernsehen und seitdem lief so etwas eben nie mehr im Fernsehen. Da fing es an und da entstand dann auch eben die Notwendigkeit der Gegenöffentlichkeit, weil das in der offiziellen Öffentlichkeit eben gar nicht mehr stattgefunden hat. Und das mit der Öffentlichkeit war ja dann doch sehr fragwürdig. Wir hatten dann irgendwelche Videobänder.
Viele.
Ja, und konnten die irgendwie auf dem Monitor immer eine Gruppe von zehn Leuten zeigen.
Nein, es war als Amerika ein Gedanke übergeschwappt, Public Access zu machen, Zugang zu Medien zu finden. Und das wurde irgendwie von der Theorie heraus in die Praxis versucht zu bringen. Rückblickend nicht uninteressant, wie weit man das jetzt als positiv oder erfahrreich bewerten kann, mag ich jetzt nicht abschließend beurteilen. Die Erfahrung ist aber interessant gewesen, nämlich zu lernen am technischen Objekt und damit umzugehen. Es war jetzt nicht die klassische Seminar- und akademische Diskussion, sondern eine praktische. Dieser Laden versuchte zumindest, durch die Tür Leute reinzubekommen, die technische Geräte anfassen konnten. Damit war eine Möglichkeit gegeben, mit der Technik was konkret zu machen. Das heißt, würde man sagen, dass die 68er sehr theoriefixiert waren, so war das sozusagen der Gegenpol, weil da konnte man eben konkret eine Videotechnik anfassen oder seine eigenen Produktionsmittel bestimmen und verbreiten. Also gab es Flugblätter, die hergestellt worden sind, es wurden eigene Bücher gemacht und es wurden eben quasi Video-, also Fernsehinhalte aufbereitet und ausgetauscht. Beispiel Wiel ist eins, weil es war auch grenzübergreifend, das heißt, Frankreich, Fessenheim war auch so ein Problemfeld. Und die Repressionsstrategien waren überall gleich. Die zogen sich von Gaulleben bis sonst etwas. Und dann gab es eben diese politischen Bewegungen, wie hier schon angesprochen, also Freirepublik Wendland oder ähnliche Sachen, die dann auch dokumentiert worden sind. Und wo diese Dokumentation dann sozusagen Anschauungsmittel war für diejenigen, die nicht dabei waren.
Also dokumentiert tatsächlich jetzt mit dem Material, was im Medienladen bereitgestellt wurde, also Geräte und Medien. Und welche Leute haben das dann sozusagen, es waren dann sozusagen Leute, die sich dann diese Anti-AKW-Szene unter anderem verdingt haben? Oder waren das dann auch schon so im Sinne von freie Journalisten, die dann die Gelegenheit genutzt haben, einfach mal selber zu so einem Bürgerreporter zu werden?
Es hatte viel damit zu tun gehabt. Der Gedanke, also was heute jetzt gemacht wird, der Leser gleich Journalist oder Produzent. Das ist natürlich etwas ironisch, aber der Gedanke war nach der brechtigen Radiotheorie und den entsprechenden kommunizierenden Röhren, also dass man sowohl Produzent als auch Rezipient sein kann.
Also ein Erlebnis ist mir noch besonders im Kopf, also ich springe jetzt ein bisschen in der Zeit, das war später aber sehr deutlich. Als Tschernobyl war, gab es in Deutschland eine Mail-Walk-Szene, über die wurden hervorragend Informationen transportiert, die in den Massenmedien nicht auftauchte. Und dann haben wir damals die Erfahrung machen müssen, dass es aber kein Back-End gab, wo man diese Informationen jetzt ausdrucken und unter die Leute bringen konnte. Und es wird mir gerade klar, das ist der qualitative Sprung mit dem Internet. Auf einmal ist auch der Distributionsapparat da.
Das heißt, dieser Medienladen hat im Prinzip schon versucht, die Leute zu produzierenden, medien-aware und auch technisch affinen Menschen zu erzielen oder zumindest dabei zu unterstützen, das zu werden. Erziehen ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit gegriffen. Aber es gab dann noch irgendwie das Problem der Distribution. Aber du hast ja gesagt, diese Berichte wurden dann teilweise auch woanders im Fernsehen gesendet.
Nicht im Fernsehen, sondern es war die Form der Gegenöffentlichkeit. Und man packte also eine Videokassette in eine Tüte und schickte sie irgendwie per Post zu jemandem anderen und konnte damit aber zeigen, was es woanders gab.
Das war manchmal ein großer Schritt zu vorher, wo eben auch das nicht möglich war. Und wie schließt sich jetzt so ein bisschen der Kreis? Also Wolf hat ja schon erzählt, er ist dann irgendwie Vau über den Weg gelaufen und Klaus dann später dann auch im Medienladen, wenn ich es jetzt richtig in Erinnerung habe. Ihr habt euch dort auch kennengelernt. Wann bist du so, Wau, das erste Mal begegnet?
Das hatte sich so ergeben, als Klaus aus Amerika wieder kam. Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wie.
Wau hast du und Wolf hast du aufgegabelt. Da saß ich in den USA, weil als ich dann wieder kam, waren die beiden, tauchten auf einmal auf und die kannte ich noch gar nicht.
Also ich habe zwischenzeitlich diese Gedanken weiterverfolgt und habe im Stadtteil Imsbüttel ein Kino gemacht. Und dieses Kino sollte eben auch eine Art von Abspielstelle sein. Und ich vermute, wenn du das jetzt so beschreibst, dass die da mal auch mit hinkommen.
Wolf meinte, das sei in der Villa Kunterbunt eingefiedelt worden, dass die da auf einmal im Blimp mit auftaucht.
Wo ist denn die Villa Kunterbunt?
Heusweg.
Gibt es hier noch unter dem Namen?
Das Haus auf jeden Fall.
Was war das?
Das war ein Wohnprojekt. Stimmt, aber ja, es sind Pferde und so. Eher Kinder.
Kinder und Pferde in der Küche.
Stimmt.
Und Blimp war der Name dieses Kinos?
Ja, es hieß zuerst Blimp und dann Lichtspieler. Und war eben ein Versuch, Musik und Galerie und Kunst und Videofilme der ansässigen Bevölkerung anzubitten.
Und wurde das auch angenommen?
Es lief ganz gut. Das war also durchaus erfolgreich. Es war mir dann zu viel. Und ich habe das dann irgendwie aufgegeben.
Jetzt kann man schon ein bisschen nachvollziehen, wie eure Aktivitäten waren. Mehr oder weniger dreht es sich immer um Technik. Teilweise Hardcore, die Programmierung, die Hardware. Und die Nutzung vor allem auch. Das kreative Nutzung. Da haben wir eigentlich schon drei schöne Schichten und Aspekte, die da immer wieder zusammenkommen. Wau wiederum wird ja auch im Nachgang häufig als Kulturfilosoph verstanden. Ich finde zu Recht, weil er eben auch immer sehr viele Aussagen darüber getroffen hat, über die Nutzung der Netze. Ich kann mich selber noch erinnern, wenn er sich dann in irgendeiner Diskussion auf irgendetwas bezog, dann sagte er dann, ja, da sucht ihr dann später nach Wau, Weihnachtsbaum und Wischmop, und dann werdet ihr das finden. Das war so eine Zeit, wo es noch nicht dieses universelle Google gab, wo man also bestenfalls ahnen konnte, dass tatsächlich diese drei Begriffe dann auch mal ausreichen würden, um so ein Snippet auch tatsächlich zu finden. Wie seid ihr da so gemeinsam dann als Gruppe zusammengekommen? Also seid ihr das überhaupt?
Ganz einfach. Ich bin dann eines Tages aus San Francisco mal wieder zu einem Zwischenaufenthalt hier nach Hamburg gekommen, weil Wolf hatte mich an Erspares vermietet, stundenweise PL1-Programmierer auf Großrechnern wurde bombig bezahlt, war stinklangweilig. Also da hatten wir drei Monate Arbeiten, immer neun Monate USA jedenfalls mitfinanziert. Das war ja ein ganz vernünftiges Verhalten. So, und dann kam ich mal mit meinem Ostborn, kam ich also an, zog dann bei Jochen in die Eppendorfer Landstraße ein und dann haben wir uns irgendwann. Dann war da diese Blimp-Mannschaft, also Jochen, Wolf und Wau. Und ich habe dann da auch mitgemacht. Und ich weiß gar nicht, wie dicht dazu eingeladen. Und jedenfalls irgendwann abends saßen wir zu fünf zusammen. Und haben so überlegt, so jetzt hier und jetzt gibt es auf einmal tragbare Rechner. Es tauchten glaube ich auch die ersten Werbungen dafür auf, dass man jetzt auch seinen eigenen Rechner haben kann. Und dann wurde uns in der Diskussion so klar, also da entsteht was. Da entsteht was und da müsste man sich doch mal Gedanken zu machen.
IBM kam mit dem Versuch nicht viel weiter.
Ja, 1981 war ja ein bewegtes Jahr. Das war, wo der Personalkomputer von IBM vorgestellt wurde.
Das war aber danach erst.
Der IBM, der erste, ich weiß gar nicht, wie er noch hieß, rich-strich-eins, 4C1 usw., das war 83. Aber zuvor war ja viel gelaufen. Also ich habe Ende der 70er-Jahre schon so eine Art Vorläufer aus Schweden kennengelernt, für die ich auch gearbeitet hatte. Das war eigentlich ein, ja, die machten Fernseher-Aberate.
Das war so ein C64-Vorläufer.
Warte mal, ja, ja, genau. Man glaubt es nicht. Also eigentlich hatten die nur Fernseher gemacht damals. Luxor hieß dieser Laden. Und die hatten da einen ganz pfiffigen Ingenieur sitzen, den ich dann auch kennenlernen konnte. Und ich war auch in Schweden oben. Der hat sich da so ein Ding ausgetüftelt, den ABC 80 hieß das Ding. Und das war im Grunde genommen schon ein Gerät wie 83, dann der von IBM. IBM hat sich ja, das machten die immer so, erst mal angesehen, wie läuft das an?
Der IBM PC ist 81 vorgestellt worden. August 81.
Aber auf jeden Fall Ende der 70. Guck mal, ob du unter ABC 80 was findest oder Luxor. Also Luxor, ABC 80. Und das war also deutlich eher. Und auch andere waren ja eher. Wir hatten ja damals eine ganz bedeutende Szene, die auf Motorola lief. Das heißt, wo ja heute noch im Prinzip der Apple drauf ist. Ist das heute noch? Der 68.000er Nachfolger oder so?
Nee, die Apples sind mittlerweile auch auf Intel eingeschränkt.
Aber der Macintosh stand ja lange für Motorola auf.
Das ist richtig.
Und das waren ja Kampfzweierlinien, kann man ja sagen. Einmal die Intel-Linie und dann die doch wesentlich bessere, aber auch sehr stark militärische Motorola-Linie.
Ja, also im Personal kommt ja der Begriff, der wurde ja im Wesentlichen auch von Apple geprägt. Also im Prinzip mit dem Apple II war die Vision an der Stelle schon erfüllt.
Wann war denn das noch mit dem Apple II?
Der kam 1978 raus.
Vorher war es ein bisschen unhandlich. Du musstest immer diesen blöden Monitor im einen Arm und dann dieses Ding da im anderen.
Das Thema Datenträger war ja noch problematisch. Also der ABC 80 hat die Daten doch tatsächlich auf so einem Audiotape da gespeichert. War zwar besser als eine Lochkarte, aber nun eben.
Oh ja, da erinnere ich mich. Ich habe doch tatsächlich meine erste Festplatte 5 Megabyte an den Ostbahn 1 angestreckt.
5 Megabyte?
Moment. Der erste Festplatte externer Speicher vom IBM. Das weiß ich noch. Der war ja nicht integriert, sondern das war ja eine eigene Station. Ich meine, der hatte 5 Megabyte.
Das habe ich aus einer Erinnerung, dass es damit mal losging.
Ja, genau. Aber auf der großen EDV waren die auch noch gar nicht so viel weiter. Die ersten waren nicht 5 Megabyte.
Das waren auch diese riesen Waschmaschinen.
Also die ersten Festplatten für die Großrechner hatten 4 Megabyte. Das weiß ich noch. Das waren aber Wechselplatten. Wir sagten immer Torten dazu.
Bisschen Baumkuchen, den man rauszieht.
Genau so. Aber die ersten davon waren wie gesagt 5 Megabyte. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Das waren auch richtig gefährliche Teile, wenn man da so schnell...
Ja, da musste man den Hauptteil seiner Zeit beim Programmieren bzw. beim Design von irgendwelchen Sachen entwerfen. Sich überlegen, wie strukturieren wir einfach mal die Daten, dass die dann auch raufgehen.
Aber um immer wieder die Kurve von der Technik wegzukriegen. Ganz wichtiges Ding ist ja hier, um die Zeit auch zu verstehen, der Tuniks-Kongress, glaube ich. Oder wenn wir überhaupt 68 sehen, so empfinde ich das so. Es war erst mal eine Revolte gegen den Muff der Angnauer Republik und praktisch das Kaiserreich. Weil durch Hitler war irgendwie eine ganze Kultur-Tradition zerstört. Und wo geht man dann hin? Dann geht man erst mal zu den Großeltern.
Unter den Talaren der Muff von 1.000 Jahren.
Und das so als eine Art Verweigerungshaltung erst mal. Also unter dem Motto so nicht. Und es hat ja doch länglich gedauert, bis sich dann unter dem Stichwort alternative Ökonomie und Projekte und Landkommune und bla und dröhnen, da was Eigenes angefangen hat, rauszubilden. Und eine ganz entscheidende Zäsur war da glaube ich der Tunix-Kongress in Berlin. Wann war das? 1979? Ja, nur 78. Wo dann so ganz viele Projekte zusammen kamen, die irgendwas Eigenes machten und ihre Arbeit davor stellten. Und deshalb haben wir damals, als wir dann 81 darüber nachgedacht haben, jetzt müssten aber auch mal die Rechner-Freaks mal zusammenkommen und überlegen, in welcher politökonomischen Gemengelage werkeln wir denn hier eigentlich, haben wir das Tuwat.Txt genannt. So hieß einfach das Pfeil. Mit einem Satzfehler wurde dann Tuwat, Txt draus.
Bei der Taz wurde das später veröffentlicht. Aber das Komma habe ich mich immer schon sehr gewundert. Aber das ist dann letztlich nur ein Unfall. Ich kann ja mal zitieren aus dieser Datei, die dann so abgedruckt wurde. Tuwat.Txt, da steht dann noch Version dahinter. Wie muss man das verstehen?
Dann fehlt wahrscheinlich Version 2 oder sowas.
Ah ja, genau. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Versionsnummer fehlt. Es war Version 2. Es wurde schon daran gearbeitet, zu dem Text. Das sieht man.
Ja, der ist ja sehr verdichtet.
Genau, da heißt es dann, dass die innere Sicherheit erst durch Computereinsatz möglich wird, glauben die Mächtigen heute alle. Das Computer nicht streiken, setzt sich als Erkenntnis langsam auch bei mittleren Unternehmen durch. Dass durch Computereinsatz das Telefon noch schöner wird, glaubt die Post heute mit ihrem Bildschirmtextsystem in Feldversuchen beweisen zu müssen. Dass der Personal Computer nun in Deutschland den videogesättigten BMW-Fahrer angedreht werden soll, wird durch die nun einsetzenden Anzeigenkampagnen klar. Dass sich mit kleinen Computern trotzdem sinnvolle Sachen machen lassen, die keine zentralisierten Großorganisationen erfordern, glauben wir. Damit wir als Computer-Freaks nicht länger unkoordiniert vor uns hin wuseln, tun wir Watt und treffen uns am 12. September 81 in Berlin, in der Wattstraße im Taz-Hauptgebäude. Wir reden über internationale Netzwerke, Kommunikationsrecht, Datenrecht, wem gehören meine Daten, Copyright, Informations- und Lernsysteme, Datenbanken, Encryption, Computerspiele, Programmiersprachen, Process-Kontrolle, Hardware und was auch immer. Damit fing es an. Unterzeichnet von Tom Twiddlebit, Wau-Wolf ungenannt, Strich 2. Also es gab 5 Leute in der Runde. Du bist Jochen, einer von den ungenannten, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Also wenn ich mir das so durchlese, ja, damit könnte man auch irgendwie den nächstjährigen Kongress ankündigen. Das ist großartig. Das ist einfach mal eine klare Vision, die sich eigentlich auch vollständig bewiesen hat und die auch, finde ich, an Aktualität wenig eingebüßt hat. Also in einer anderen Dimension ist das irgendwie immer noch eine gute Bildschirmtext. Muss man jetzt mal durch was anderes ersetzen. Aber im Kern kämpfen wir immer noch mit diesem Feldversuchen, ob es irgendwie Wahlcomputer oder andere Systeme sind.
Auf dem Postbanking, da gibt es noch BTX irgendwo.
Ja, war ja auch schön zu sehen, dass ja ausgerechnet das Bildschirmtextsystem auch sehr prägend war für die erste Zeit des Chaos Computer Clubs. Dieser erste Hack, mit dem der Club dann auch bekannt wurde und auch eine Menge Experience gesammelt hat mit Datennetzen.
Das kam durch die IFA in dem Jahr. Da waren wir alle auf der IFA. Da war nämlich die Schwarz-Schilling-Vorstellung, die das BTX jetzt flächendeckend eingeführt hat.
Ah ja, 1981 auch.
80 oder 81.
Also die IFA war glaube ich immer im September?
Dann muss es 80 gewesen sein.
Dann muss es 80 gewesen sein nach Tuwat.
Kann sein. Das war dann, glaube ich, die IFA war in den letzten zwei Jahren. Das können wir auch noch mal rauskriegen, aber spielt ja keine Rolle. Das heißt, hier hat sich im Prinzip so ein bisschen auch der Wunsch einer alternativen, also im Prinzip auch wieder einer Gegenöffentlichkeit, aber eben mit diesem Computerbezug formuliert. Und das erschien dann in der Zeitung. Und wann erschien das in der Zeitung? 1.9.81. Also es hatte gerade mal 11 Tage Vorlauf. Und was hatte das dann? Warum überhaupt bei der Taz? Warum in Berlin, wenn ihr eigentlich alle in Hamburg wart und euch in Hamburg getroffen habt? Das ist jetzt noch ein bisschen eine Frage.
Na ja, also durch die Taz hatten wir einen guten lauten Lautsprecher. Das wurde damit bundesweit breit getreten. Und dann gab es eben die Chance, dass auch ein paar Leute zusammen kamen. Und das war ja dann auch so.
Das war auch so von vornherein eigentlich der Wunsch, dass man gleich auch bundesweit, also dass man gar nicht erst...
Wir haben uns natürlich Taz nahe gesehen. Demzufrage. Und Taz war die einzige nationale verbreitete Zeitung.
Und es war zur damaligen Zeit auch irgendwie ganz klar, dass das gebracht würde.
Und so Taz Hamburg, in dem Sinne gab es ja auch noch, glaube ich, gar nicht.
War noch nicht gegründet.
Das heißt, es wurde dann veröffentlicht, und dann habt ihr euch da auch getroffen. Taz Hauptgebäude, 11 Uhr. Und wer kam?
20 bis 25 Leute. Ich glaube, die Namensliste gibt es nicht mehr. Nur das Protokoll, was wir damals...
Ach, es gibt das Protokoll?
Das Protokoll gibt es noch. Das habe ich ja brav geschrieben danach. Und das ist noch nachzulesen. Das hat Andy auch mal eingescannt irgendwann. Das liegt noch bei mir auf dem Rechner. Und danach gab es noch mal ein Münchner Treffen. Also weil die Schwerpunkte mäßig waren, Leute aus München, aus Berlin und aus Hamburg da.
München, Berlin, Hamburg? Gibt es da Erklärungen für? Warum ausgerechnet? Also Berlin ist klar, weil das hat ja in Berlin stattgefunden.
Und München ist auch ganz klar, weil es ein deutsches Technologiezentrum ist.
Da ist die Computerindustrie angedockt, vor allem. Nachvollziehbar. Keine Hannoveraner? Hatte die C-Bit noch nicht so viele Auswirkungen.
Waren das die gleichen Münchner, mit denen wir nachher auf der Systems waren, bei denen wir dann auch zwei Tage wohnten?
Ja, das war ja das zweite Treffen. Das war ja nach dem Berliner Treffen, dann das Münchner... Ach, das war an der Systems angewunden.
Das war an der Systems, ja. Das war an der Systems angewunden, das erinnere ich noch genau. Ich erinnere auch noch, wo wir da gekampiert haben.
Das heißt, die Systems gab es damals schon, die Cebit gab es damals ja noch gar nicht.
Na Moment, die Cebit?
Das gab die Hannover Messe, die dann halt Cebit als Halle hatte, aber die Cebit als eigenständige Messe, in dem Sinne gab es S86. Oh, die Systems gab es schon 1969.
Wahnsinn, ja.
Das älteste IT-Fachmesse der Welt, wer hätte das gewusst? Hm, wir sind beeindruckt. Ja, aber die Entwicklung der Besucherzahlen sind auch nicht so toll. Messen haben es einfach sehr schwer im Internetzeitalter. Ja, aber jetzt vielleicht nochmal zurück zu diesem Treffen. Also da trafen dann 20, 25 Leute aufeinander. Und was wurde dann so? Kannst du mal das Protokoll so ein bisschen aus dem Kopf... Nein, also ich habe nicht wortwörtlich.
Also nachdem es Andy eingescannt hat, ich habe es nochmal gelesen und ich habe gedacht, boah, waren wir damals gut. Also das war im gleichen Stil wie da dieser Aufruftext. Wurde wirklich ernsthaft gearbeitet an einer kritisch, politisch, kulturell, was der Rechner nun eigentlich für ein Phänomen ist und wo das wohl hingehen mag.
Eine Vision, eine echte Vision.
Ja, aber was war denn die Vision jetzt? Also was war denn so der Konsens dieser Runde, wenn es einen gab? Wohin die Reise geht. Ich meine, das haben sich ja in der Zeit auch viele Hoffnungen geknüpft und wie wir wissen, es hat immer alles so zwei Seiten. Der Rechner ist die Befreiungsmaschine auf der einen Seite. Auf der anderen Seite wurde ja auch gerade von der linken Szene der Computer selbst dann auch eher als Bedrohung wahrgenommen. Und war dann so irgendwie das System der Großcomputer, der beherrschenden Massen, womit man dann irgendwie die Arbeiter dann sich mit sparen konnte, auf lange Sicht. Du hast ja auch dann in der Folge eine andere Organisation gegründet als den CCC, nämlich die APOC.
Wo stand das? Das war ja aber glaube ich auch schon vom ersten Treffen an klar, dass es Fraktionen, wäre vielleicht zu viel gesagt, aber es gab ja natürlich den Aspekt, diejenigen, die an den existierenden Systemen manchmal verzweifeln, wie dämlich die sind. Und diejenigen, die sich mehr dafür interessieren, so unter dem Motto, also lass die Industrie doch mit ihren Fehlern selber fertig werden, die sollen dafür bezahlen, wenn ich die korrigiere. Und was können wir denn mit den Kisten eigentlich sozial Emanzipatives machen? Und was sind Sachen, die es noch nicht gibt? Und was kann man da so machen? Und die zwei Strömungen hat es schon gegeben. Und ich würde sagen, so in der Anfangszeit, na vielleicht noch, wie der Chaos Computer Club entstanden ist, ich weiß es nicht. Weil diese Treffen hießen ja nicht Chaos Computer Club oder so.
Das heißt, dieser Begriff ist eigentlich bei diesem Treffen auch überhaupt nicht gefahren. Also von einer wirklichen Gründung des Clubs in dem Sinne kann man da eigentlich auch gar nicht reden.
Nö.
Doch. Wäre man nur nicht als Club, so in dem Sinne.
Ja und auch nicht unter dem Namen.
Wir sind regelmäßig Mittagessen gegangen. Das artete immer zu einen längeren Palawan aus. Wir sind immer in die Kantine vom Bezirksamt gegangen. Und zwar Wolf, du, Wau und ich. Über Monate hinweg. Das ist mir völlig entfallen.
Du warst gar nicht. Dabei. Nie, nie, nie. Nach dem Münchner Treffen bin ich wieder nach San Francisco und habe dann noch ein halbes Jahr gehockt. Dann hast du mich zum Filmfest zurückgerufen. Ja, das stimmt. Als ich dann zurückkam, traf ich dann Wau wieder. Dann erzählte er mir freudig dran, dass wir den Chaos Computer Club gegründet haben. Das lief in der Zeit, als ich gar nicht hier war. Das war dann die Zeit mit Schwarzmark, Bundesstraße 10 sozusagen als Maledrop. Der Chaos Club hatte ja diesen Hintergrund, Tap-Newsletter und hatte deshalb diese Atmosphäre von diesem Halblegalen, was mich immer etwas genervt hat. Deshalb gab es die APOC, als eine Organisation, wo man überlegen konnte, was man jetzt eigentlich nach vorne machen kann.
Arbeitskreis politisches Computern, habt ihr das genannt.
Ja, Arbeitskreis politischer Computereinsatz.
Computer-Einsatz, ja.
Es gibt dann widersprechende Versionen davon. Aber wo es rumging, war ja eigentlich, wir hatten dann erkannt, dass es nun E-Mail gibt. Und dass das die billigste Art ist, international zu kommunizieren. Und das haben wir halt versucht, hier in Hamburg einigen NGO's beizubiegen. Die Gesellschaft für Bedrohte Völker war da sofort begeistert dabei. Und andere, die nicht so international tätig waren, waren auf der Linie der grünen Hagener Beschlüsse, die da hießen, der Computer ist des Teufels.
Du hattest damals doch dieses 300-Boot-Modem entwickelt.
Nö, entwickelt nicht. Ich hatte mir in den USA eins gekauft, um dann festzustellen, dass die Töne hier anders sind. Und da musste ich da irgendwie noch ein paar Kondensatoren zulöten, um die Frequenz zu ändern.
Aber das war ja sehr erfolgreich.
Das war dann so eine Art Datenklo.
Sogar mit FTZ, mit Darmstadt. Das war das sehr beeindruckend.
Wie ihr das in die Einladung bekommen habt.
Ach so, das ist noch eine ganz andere Geschichte. Das war aber viel später. So viel später kann das nicht gewesen sein. Wo ich mein Geld damit verdient habe, irgendwelchen japanischen PC-Herstellern ihre FTZ-Nummer in Saarbrücken zu erwerben für ihre serielle Schnittstelle, damit auch die heiligen Post-Modems angeschlossen werden.
Das war unser eigenes Modem. Das haben wir selbst gebaut.
Das Thiele-Modem.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das Ding hieß. Fast 300 Boot, man konnte fast so mit...
Nein, 1200 hin und 75 Boot Rückkanal.
BTX-kompatibel.
Ja, mit Einschub. Euro-Pakaten-Einschub.
Wie?
Da habe ich damals ein Z80-System drum gestrickt, um das dann in vieler Korrektur leerzupacken.
Das hast du ja selbst entwickelt noch. Das meinte ich. Ach, das war 300 und Rückkanal 75.
Nein, 1275.
Okay, wir verlieren uns ein bisschen. Also klar ist, es gab jetzt dieses Treffen. Da müssen wir noch ein bisschen darüber reden. Wau hat dann sozusagen da seine eigene Botschaft mit rausgenommen und später mit anderen Leuten auch wirklich dem Kind einen Namen gegeben. Aber es war schon so, dass in diesem Treffen irgendwie so Leute zusammen kamen, die einfach sich einig waren, dass an diesem Geist, in diesem Text der Einladung ja schon spricht, einfach was dran war. Dass einfach mal was getan werden muss, dass man sich in irgendeiner Form zusammenfinden muss. Und naja, ich weiß nicht, habt ihr irgendwie Erkenntnisse oder ein Gefühl, wie viele von diesen Leuten, die nun wirklich daran teilgenommen haben an diesem Treffen, dann auch danach in irgendeiner Form in solche Strukturen hineingetragen wurden? Schwer zu sagen.
Ich habe auch gar keinen Überblick, was zum Beispiel die Münchner Hackerpost, inwieweit da Urväter, also schon auch bei den Münchner Treffen dabei waren, obwohl ich mir das gut vorstellen kann.
Bayerische Hackerpost.
Lang, lang ist zäher.
Lang, lang ist zäher, ja, das muss ich auch nochmal aufarbeiten. Ich habe die einmal kennengelernt, so ganz am Anfang. Da war ich mal bei irgendeinem Treffen.
Also ganz wichtig für die damalige Zeit waren ja auch die neue Mailboxen im K, was der Versuch war, eben kommerziell E-Mail zu machen zu einer Zeit, als es das ja eigentlich noch gar nicht gab.
Als das Ad noch nicht erfunden war.
Oh, das Ad hat lange gebraucht. Das Ad hat lange gebraucht. Ja, wir haben ja heute den 17. Februar, gestern vor genau 30 Jahren, wurde die erste Computer-Mailbox in Betrieb genommen worden, in Chicago. In einem Schneesturm entstand der Bedarf, doch mal kommunizieren zu können, ohne das Haus zu verlassen, sodass da halt wirklich die erste vernetzte, über das Telefon erreichbare Mailbox entstand. Bord Christensen hat das gemacht, der dann später auch mit den dafür entwickelten Technologien bekannt wurde, X-Mode, Datenübertragungsprotokolle, unsere Geschichten. Ja, und es hat ja dann auch nicht so lange gedauert, bis auch dieser Mailbox-Trend Deutschland erfasst hat. Gerade hier in Hamburg gab es einige Projekte. Womit fing das an? War das die Tornado-Box oder die Clinch? Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau.
Na, die Clinch-Box, das war noch eine mit einer. Damit fing es eigentlich so, wie ich es wahrgenommen habe, an. Reinhard Schruzki, der das dann auch einen ganzen Ladendrome rumbaute. Das war dann aber auch schon im Zusammenhang mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Das muss so 1983 gewesen sein, die Richtung. Und der Quantensprung war dann die Tornado-Box, wo dann eben mehr als eine Telefonleitung reinlief und man nun auf einmal auch chatten konnte.
Vorher rief man halt an und hinterlegte was. Genau, so ein bisschen wie zum Postfach gehen.
Aber das hatte ja auch schon eine ungeheure Kommunikationsdynamik mit allen Erfahrungen, die eben auch heute noch alle, die dumm User mit der E-Mail machen. Das Ironie geht nicht und wie schnell man sich da in Flame Wars ausbrechen kann. Das wurde ja damals alles erstmalig so erprobt.
Gab es da eigentlich noch den Akustikkoppler? Das war ja ein Ding aus der Frühzeit der Kommunikation.
Oh ja, den habe ich noch bis Ende der 80er Jahre. Da war der noch ganz gut im Einsatz, weil das ja auch die einzige Möglichkeit war, ohne Postzulassung und damit nochmal mit extra Geld die Bestrafung kommunizieren zu können. Und danach wurden dann halt die Modems so erschwinglich und die Telekom hat ja noch eine Weile versucht, alle Leute zu bestrafen dafür, dass sie sich in den USA Modems kaufen. Aber irgendwann haben sie ja auch mal eingesehen, dass das alles totaler Quatsch ist. Ja, schon interessant. Und das war dann auch richtig irgendwie strafbewehrt. Das war dann nicht irgendwie mal nur eine Ordnungswidrigkeit, sondern irgendwie das hochoffizielle Kabel anfassen. Das kommt gleich nach Mord. Alles sehr schön realitätsfern. Viel ist eigentlich auch extrem. Realitätsfern war, was Datenkommunikation betraf. Also man hat es ja sehr schwer, Leuten zu erklären, was man eigentlich so treibt, wenn man in Datennetzen unterwegs ist, sich mit Mailboxen oder eben auch der Frühform des Internet auseinandersetzt. Aber ich würde jetzt ganz gerne noch mal so ein bisschen noch dieses Tuwatreffen als solches, noch ein bisschen verstehen, was denn eigentlich da die Inhalte waren. Also ist das jetzt nur so, naja, es gibt jetzt irgendwie Personalcomputer und jetzt müssen wir irgendwie, jetzt müssen wir damit spielen? Oder war das schon so ein bisschen auch beseelt davon, da eine breitere Bewegung auf die Beine zu stellen? Und warum sollen jetzt die Computerfreaks da an der Stelle eine andere Rolle spielen als andere Gruppen?
Nur an breitere Bewegung kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass wir daran gedacht haben. Wir waren halt da, es waren überraschend viele Leute zusammengekommen mit diesem kleinen Aufruf.
25 Leute finde ich viel, ja.
Da war offensichtlich die Zeit reif gewesen, so was mal zu machen.
Ich glaube, jeder, der mit Computern Kontakt hatte, wenn er das Wort Computer in einer Zeitung gelesen hat, wurde schon sehr hellhörig, weil das existierte ja eigentlich nicht.
Wir haben uns ja aber durch den Text doch sehr deutlich abgegrenzt oder klargemacht, dass wir an der politischen Dimension interessiert sind und nicht an den Leuten, die das aus Prestige gründen oder weil sie damit besonders meinten, besonders viel Kohle ganz schnell verdienen zu können oder so. Und dann 25, das war ja doch sehr beachtlich. Also das war schon ganz klar das erste Treffen, dass es um politische Sachen ging und nicht um eine technische Sache eigentlich. Na wie gesagt, also ich hatte dann mit dieser Hackerorientierung vom Chaos Club hatte ich so meine Schwierigkeiten und deshalb eben auch die APOC mit einer mehr politischen Zielrichtung. Und da bin ich eben so sehr erfreut, wie eben der Chaos Club sich in den letzten Jahren entwickelt hat, weil ich denke, er ist eigentlich genau wieder da, wo wir es bei diesem ersten Treffen angedacht hatten in der Zielrichtung. Und das richtig kräftig inzwischen.
Ich meine, wenn mir jetzt so diese Fragestellungen, die in diesem Aufruf drin waren, ich meine, wir reden über internationale Netzwerke, das tun wir, ja, Kommunikationsrecht ist...
Du redest jetzt von Tuwat.Txt?
Ja, ja, genau. Ich zitiere hier nochmal so, Kommunikationsrecht ist irgendwie allgegenwärtig, Datenrecht, wem gehören meine Daten, also jetzt gerade im aktuellen Social Networks-Hype, also, da könnt ihr das jetzt keine brandaktuelle Formulierung finden. Ja, Copyright, auch ein Dauerbrenner, auch damals hatte das sicherlich noch keiner so richtig auf der Agenda. Gut Informations-Lernsysteme, Datenbanken usw. sind so technische Nebenschauplätze, aber dann geht es halt schon wieder weiter mit Encryption, also 1981 jetzt schon über Verschlüsselung zu reden. Was hat euch dazu bewegt, das da auf die Liste mit aufzunehmen?
Sind wir drauf gekommen.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, was... Man lernt ja auch über offene Netze, unsere offene Kommunikationskultur usw. auch das Internet, das frühe, was damals noch gar nicht so als solches existierte.
Aber das ist eine ganz naheliegende Geschichte eigentlich. Also mit Encryption, also finde ich so. Das ist ja nicht neu. Das gibt es ja seit Menschengedenken, möchte ich mal sagen. Das ist doch nur transportiert worden auf dieses neue Medium.
Ja, ach so.
Also Geheimschrift hat doch nun wirklich Geschichte.
Ja gut, aber Geheimschrift hat ja wohl ein bisschen mehr mit geheimer, clandestiner Kommunikation und entsprechenden Organisationen zu tun, während hinter Encryption heute ja eigentlich sehr viel mehr. Also das einzige Wort, was mir jetzt hier noch drin fehlt, was ja eigentlich auch schon mit der Ursuppe des Clubs zu tun hat, ist Privatsphäre. Das steckt für mich jetzt so ein bisschen bei der ersten Betrachtung dahinter. Und das erfordert natürlich schon eine gewisse, da muss man schon recht weit blicken, dass man überhaupt Daten als einen Teil des privaten Lebens versteht. Das ist heutzutage, sagen wir mal, jedem jungen Computereinsteiger, dann muss man das nicht länger als fünf Sekunden erklären. Allerdings ist unsere politische Klasse jetzt gerade mit aktuellen Trends zu, naja, wir müssen ja mal Online-Durchsuchungen machen und ihre Festplatten mitnehmen und dann werden irgendwie ganze Computermarkten konfestiert, wenn man in ein anderes Land den Zoll passiert. Ja, so wir nehmen das mal mit. Sie kriegen das ja auch alles wieder. Da scheint überhaupt noch überhaupt kein richtiges Verständnis dafür zu sein. Deswegen interessiert mich das immer, warum wir uns damals so gesehen haben.
Die Zeit war damals nicht repressionsfrei. Also wir haben damals den entsprechenden Druck gehabt, sei es in verschiedenen sozialen Bewegungen, AKW oder dieser sogenannte Bleyern Herbst war auch nicht ewig lange zurück. Und da war es natürlich so, dass natürlich Überwachungsmaßnahmen stattgefunden haben.
Bis hin zu dem Punkt, wie dieses Tuwat.Txt unterschrieben war. Eben nicht mit klaren Namen. Weil uns schon bewusst war, dass es eben auch ein brisanter Text ist. Also jetzt an diesen ganzen technischen Gerätschaften mal politisch drüber nachzudenken, was das eigentlich ist. Also ich bin mir nicht drüber im Plan mit der Encryption, ob du uns da jetzt nicht ein bisschen viel Ehre zuschiebst, ob wir überhaupt schon an Datenkommunikation gedacht hatten. Aber Encryption im militärischen Bereich, also der ganze Punkt war ja Folklore, wie nun Atomraketen irgendwie gestartet werden und das gesicherte Kommunikationswege. Ich glaube, es hatte eher mit der Lichtung zu tun.
Na dann steckt Computersicherheit mit drin. Das ist ja auch nicht gerade uninteressant.
Also der Brief ist eben älter als die Postkarte, denke ich mal. Also wenn es geht, nicht jeder ist Exkursionist. Obwohl man heute im Internet vielleicht den Eindruck kriegen kann, dass die Sachen überpräsentiert sind.
Als jetzt Wau ankam, ich meine, da wart ihr dann mit Wau noch in Verbindung, als er dann sozusagen den Namen CCC benutzt hat. Und seid ihr dann sozusagen mit dem Club in irgendeiner Form noch in Verbindung gewesen in den ersten Jahren?
Ja ich ja schon, so immer mal wieder als Gast.
Als er da im Keller wohnte, da gab es so eine Schwenkestrasse. Ja, da waren wir öfter. Und das war CCC? Eindeutig. Wir haben auch Datenschleider-Diskussionen da gehabt und die Papiere entsprechend aufbereitet. Also ich hab ihn da auch häufiger besucht. Aber wenn ich jetzt erzählen soll, worüber wir gesprochen haben.
Das war immer ungeheurer tiefsinnig.
Deshalb haben wir es wohl auch vergessen.
Ja gut, aber ihr habt schon auch gesehen, dass in der Folge dieses Treffens dann auch wirklich so eine real greifbare Struktur entstanden ist. Da waren ja dann auch noch andere Leute dazugekommen, die jetzt bei den ursprünglichen Treffen wohl nicht mit dabei waren. Ich weiß jetzt nicht so genau, wer in den ersten Jahren da jetzt wirklich regelmäßig aufgetaucht ist.
Das ist doch die Zeit, als Andy Scursor verloren ging, oder wie?
Ja, das war aber ja schon ziemlich spät. Das war ja als dann Steffen Aufflug, dass er Beraterjobs in der Industrie mit seinen Informationen, die da in der Bundesstraße ankamen, übernommen hat. Also ich denke so, der Chaos Computer Club ist ganz entscheidend, dass Wau und Steffen zusammengekommen sind. Und da ging der Chaos Computer Club los. Und ja, klar, es war ganz deutlich, aber das auch schon eigentlich beim ersten Treffen und dann bei München. Das ist was, das bewegt Menschen und immer mehr und das lebt. Und so, das ist ja auch kräftig weitergewachsen.
Oh ja, das kann man nicht von der Hand weisen. Erstaunlich. Obwohl es natürlich auch immer so seine Höhen und Tiefen hatte, aber die letzte Tiefe ist jetzt schon eine Weile her. Ich bin eigentlich auch sehr zuversichtlich, dass das noch eine Weile braucht, bis das wieder untergeht, was wir uns jetzt gerade aufgebaut haben. Was ich vorhin angesprochen habe, die Sache mit der APOC. Da hast du ja im Prinzip auch mit dem Club sozusagen, mit den anderen zusammengearbeitet an dieser Studie für die Grünen. Das hatte ich ja vorhin erwähnt. So linke Szene hat sich eigentlich sehr schwer getan mit Computern. Worum ging es bei dieser Studie? Was habt ihr da erarbeitet?
Die Bundestagsverwaltung hatte sich nun überlegt, dass auch der Arbeitsplatz des Abgeordneten computerisiert und rationalisiert werden kann und hatte Haushaltsmittel zur Verfügung gestellt, die dann nach Proporz von den einzelnen Fraktionen vergeben werden konnten, um in einer ersten Phase das studienmäßig aufzuarbeiten.
Wann war denn das?
Dann tauchte in der Taz eines Tages eine Anzeige von der Grünen Fraktion im Bundestag auf, dass man jetzt eine Studie in Auftrag geben will. Da haben wir uns dann, ich glaube, wir waren insgesamt zu acht, vier vom CCC und vier von der APOC und haben uns zusammengesetzt und gemeinsam beworben und auch die Grünen haben damals zwei Studien gemacht, einmal an die Hamburger, wie wir dann da hießen, und einmal an eine Firma, die kam, glaube ich, das Freiburg. Das Ende vom Lied war die Hamburger. Wir haben gestört und die Freiburger haben gesagt, welche Rechner man kaufen soll. Und zwar haben wir deshalb gestört, weil wir erstmal grundsätzlich hinterfragt haben, was läuft denn da eigentlich für eine Arbeit ab, bei den Abgeordneten. Das war eine sehr schöne, privilegierte Situation. Wir konnten da im Tulpenfeld-Hochhaus rumtapern und in jedes Büro gehen und hallo, wir sind die Hamburger und was macht der hier eigentlich? Und dann sind uns ja die Illusionen ganz schnell zu Bruch gegangen, also von wegen die aufbruchbefeuerte, progressive, grüne Fraktion, da kriegten wir mit, wie da die Grabenkämpfe stattfinden, wie inzwischen diejenigen sich nach vorne gespielt hatten, für die es wichtig war, dass ihre Mama ihr Bild in der Zeitung sieht. Und das war damals auch schon die Zeit, dass die Leute, die insbesondere im Umweltbereich inhaltlich arbeiten wollten, wo die dann wieder zur SPD gingen, weil sie sagten, also diese Bevormundung hier bei den Grünen, das müssen wir uns nicht antun. Und in dieser Gemengelage haben wir dann die Frechheit besessen, eigentlich in der Studie zu sagen, liebe Leute, lernt erst mal mit Karteikarten umzugehen, um wie man die Büroarbeit organisiert. Und dann könnt ihr mal überlegen, Computer zu benutzen. Weil wenn ihr gleich Computer benutzt, dann wird das Chaos ja wirklich ganz undurchdringlich. Und haben als praktischen Schritt vorgeschlagen, ich glaube, wir hatten es die Computerstube oder so genannt. Also, dass es da einen Raum geben soll, wo jemand sitzt, der Ahnung davon hat, und wo es so zwei, drei Rechner gibt und was es so an Peripherie gibt, und dass man sich das da angucken kann.
So eine Art Internet-Café.
Und es ist natürlich als nichts draus geworden. Weil die Fraktionsgeschäftsführung wollte halt ihre Buchhaltung mit dem Rechner machen und wollte eigentlich nur wissen, welche Maschine und welche Software sie sich kaufen sollen. Und während es tachüber noch immer hieß, oh Gott, nein, Computer, Gott sei bei uns, wurden wir abends an der Theke beim Bier gefragt, wie gut ein Wordstar ist. Ganz wichtig für uns als Arbeitsgruppe war, wir waren ja nun acht Leute, die von der Schweiz bis Hamburg und Berlin alle verteilt und auch in verschiedenen konverziellen Projekten gearbeitet und die ganze Koordinationsarbeit und das gemeinsame Werk wurde über die IMCA Mailbox abgewickelt und das war für mich wirklich der Einstieg, dass so eine verteilte Gruppenarbeit über so ein Mailbox-System tatsächlich möglich ist. Irgendwo in Hessen, was dann später die Deutsche Mailbox GmbH in Hamburg wurde, bis sie eben durch das Internet und die Realität überrollt wurde.
Naja, also das war dann auch tatsächlich ein Werkzeug, die Mailboxen. Also bevor es Internet gab, schickte man sich halt irgendwie zwar auch schon E-Mail, aber eben nicht auf den jeweils anderen Rechner, sondern das lag dann alles in der Mailbox und da wählte man sich dann ein.
Genau und das war eine wichtige Erfahrung, also für alle, dass das eben wirklich ein Koordinationsinstrument ist, wo man so ein ganzes, doch ziemlich komplexes Projekt mit koordinieren kann.
Jochen, du hast ja vorhin den bleierenden Herbst erwähnt, damit man es jetzt den Terror-Herbst, den deutschen Herbst nehme ich an. Was hatte denn das so für eine Auswirkung auf die Gesellschaft und dann sozusagen auf das, was ihr da so beschlossen und gedacht habt in dem Zusammenhang, also von diesem Bedrohungsszenario her?
Wir haben auf der einen Seite versucht, Gegenöffentlichkeit dagegen zu halten, das heißt, man bekam einige Filme aus Berlin, die gedreht worden sind, um bestimmte Aufmarschen der Polizei zu zeigen oder ähnliches. Dann gab es die ganze RAF-Hysterie und in dem Zusammenhang natürlich dann auch Druck auf einzelne Leute und mir fällt Wau in dem Zusammenhang ein, der sich da extrem aufgerücht hatte drüber und für den das also auch eine Art von ganz starker Bedrohung und Bedrückung war. Also er hatte da auch erhebliche Stimmungsschwankungen.
Das heißt, dass sozusagen die Tatsache, dass dieser Terror-Habs so ablief, wie er ablief, dann Repressionen der Gesellschaft nach sich zog.
Wir wollten uns natürlich nicht reinsteigern in so eine Situation, aber wir fanden es schon als gewissermaßen bedrückend. Also es war ja nicht eine Aufbruchsstimmung, sondern wenn man so etwas eher in der Abwehr hält.
Was genau fandet ihr jetzt so bedrückend? Also die Tatsache, dass jetzt die Leute sozusagen sich jetzt für Terror entschieden haben und dass das so ein Auswuchs dieser alternativen Bewegung war oder die Rückmeldung des Staates war?
Wir haben uns natürlich nicht angetraut, die RAF oder ähnliches zu bewerten in dem Sinne. Sondern wir haben uns angetraut zu sagen, dass wir bestimmte Maßnahmen, die der Staat trifft, nicht unsere Zustimmung finden. Und wir waren alle Brockdorf nass oder Gauleben nass und ähnliches. Also von daher war das der Grundtenor der Stimmung. Das Suchen nach neuen Möglichkeiten war das eine. Aber die Befürchtung, dass es in einem Konflikt sich äußert, das andere. Also gab es natürlich diejenigen, die mehr gewachschaftlich organisiert waren oder gedacht haben, haben natürlich gesagt, das ist Arbeitsplatzabbau. Und da gab es dann diese ganzen Gutachten, dass man krummen Rücken kriegt oder ähnliche komischen Verspannungen und so etwas. Und dann hieß es, was weiß ich, ob die Bildschirme verspiegelt werden müssen oder nicht. Und so etwas. Also das waren alles damals durchaus Themen. Bildschirm, Arbeitsplatzgestaltung. Genau.
Das, was sich in diesem Tuwat-Dokument manifestiert, das ist ja auch schon eine Vision. Schon so ein bisschen der Blick nach vorne. Man hat das Gefühl, die Technik wird einfach bestimmte Teile der Gesellschaft und dann letztlich auch das private Lebens beeinflussen. Was ja so zwei andere sehr populäre Meme sind, die damals schon eine Rolle gespielt haben, ist natürlich auf der einen Seite Science-Fiction-Literatur, die es ja auch zu dem Zeitpunkt schon gegeben hat. Ich weiß nicht, hat euch das beeinflusst? So generell jetzt nicht unbedingt im Zusammenhang mit dem Tuwat, aber so ist das ein bedächtiges Nicken.
Ich weiß nicht, das war nicht mein Ich war auch kein Perry Roden-Fan.
So Cyberspace-Visionen und...
Ja, aber bei John Brunner zum Beispiel. Das war ja aber schon später, ne? Das war, meine ich, in den 70er-Jahren fängt er an. Das kann man aber feststellen.
Der Schockwellenreiter ist von 1975.
Das war sehr visionär.
Ja, das ist wahr. Da ist ja auch schon dieses Cyberpunk-Thema im Prinzip so aufgekommen und so auch so dieser, naja, vielleicht nicht jetzt nicht der Begriff Hacker, aber schon so also auch das sich gut auskennende Individuum, was die Technik gut im Griff hat und dabei leben kann.
Aber das hat so in der Gründungsphase eigentlich noch keine Rolle gespielt. Das wurde dann sozusagen erst später entdeckt, dass es sowas auch gibt in der science fiction Literatur.
Und das zweite Meme, was sicherlich auch stark war, ob das jetzt bei euch stark war, weiß ich eben nicht, deswegen frage ich, war ja so, dass 1984 vor der Tür stand. Ja, dieses Jahr sozusagen der Inbegriff als Zahl schon des allmächtigen Staates, der alles überwacht und seine Bürger schön im Zaum hält und ihn vorschreibt, was sie zu tun und zu denken haben. Spielte das eine Rolle? Ich mit meinen Thesen, ihr mit den Schultern.
Ich habe es damals schon gekannt, jedenfalls. Das hat sicherlich eine Rolle gespielt.
Das war ja schon über 30 Jahre alt, da hat er 48 geschrieben.
Ja, da hat er einfach die Zahlen umgedreht.
Ich denke schon, dass Orwell das auch schon gemacht hat.
Das ist nicht nur 1984, er hat auch noch andere sehr tiefsinnige und schockierende Dinge geschrieben.
Gerade Essays. Letztlich ist es ja auch so gekommen, dass der Club 1984 eigentlich erst so richtig Fahrt aufgenommen hat. Die Jahre davor waren eigentlich eher ein, es gab ihn und es gab Leute, die mit diesem Namen irgendwas getan haben. Aber 1984 fand auf einmal so eine Verdichtung statt. Der erste Kongress fand statt, die Datenschleuder wurde das erste Mal publiziert. Sicherlich dann auch so ein bisschen im Kielwasser dieses Hypes. Ich erinnere mich jetzt nicht mehr so richtig daran, wie das war. Da war ich noch ein bisschen zu jung, aber es war schon so dieses, oh Gott, man wusste so, oh Gott, jetzt ist 1. Januar 1984, jetzt geht es los.
Wenn ich jetzt meinen Bildschirm einschalte, meinen Fernseher, dann gucken sie zurück und da waren nicht auch schon die ersten Atomkatastrophen, wie wir so nennen, gelaufen. Einmal Enrico Fermi, ich glaube, das war das erste und dann Streamiles Island. Ja, das muss da gewesen sein, hab ich so vermutlich mal. War schon gelaufen. Chernobyl kam ja 1986 erst. Ja, und der andere auch. Da waren wir auch hart am Abgrund gewesen.
Doch, also wenn ich so darüber nachdenke, das stimmt schon, wenn du den ganzen Tuwat.Txt so einfach von einer Tendenz her, da ist Orwell wirklich drin. Unbedingt.
Und der allmächtige Staat, also diese Art der Energieerzeugung produziert den absolut mächtigen Staat. Wenn wir hier jeder unsere Windkraftanlage auf dem Dach sitzen haben, dann brauchen wir den da, finde ich, aber für ein Atomkraftwerk ist der einfach notwendig.
Das Atomkraftwerk war schon damals eigentlich so ein bisschen das Symbol dieses allmächtigen Staates. Deswegen hat sich da auch die Energie so dagegen gewendet, also der Leute.
Hast du mal geguckt, wann Herr Rissberg war?
Ich versuche gerade hier diese Information herauszufinden.
Aus der Alvesnömen Müllhalde. Das war in der Zeit dieses friedliche Indikator. Genau, von Holger Strom. Da hatte ich damals auch einen Teil zu geschrieben. Genau, da fällt mir auch noch ein.
Das war zum Tunics-Kongress, ganz wichtig war auch Robert Jung damals.
Oh ja, das spielt eine große Rolle.
Der Zukunftsforscher.
Genau, heller als tausend Sonnen.
Wie kannst du in diesem Kongress noch mal ein bisschen was erzählen? Der hat ja nun auch gerade vor kurzem ein großes Revival gehabt in Berlin. Es gab eine Veranstaltung dazu, die ich leider verpasst habe.
Das war nur furchtbar. Es war nur furchtbar, voll und drängelig. Also hier Hamburg-Hafengeburtstag. Harmlos. Harmlos.
20.000 Leute waren da oder so.
Oder einige tausend.
Es gibt da so Schätzungen von 5 bis 20.
Das war der totale Wahnsinn. Das hat richtig reingeknallt, das Ding. Das war auch eine Veranstaltung, die in Zeit reif war.
Und da kamen irgendwie alle zusammen und was passierte da?
Man hat gegenseitig sich wahrgenommen und festgestellt, oh, so was, was wir hier in unserer kleinen Gruppe machen, davon gibt es noch ganz viele andere. Das hat Mut gemacht. Und vor allen Dingen, es war auch eine ganz klare Gegenthese auch nach außen. Also schon alleine dieser Titel, Tu nix, das war ja die Verneinung. Die Veranstaltung ging ja genau um das Gegenteil eigentlich. Und es war auch, glaube ich, eine Befreiung aus dem deutschen Herbst. Jetzt aus dieser bedrückenden Herbststimmung heraus, mit tief hängenden Wolken jetzt ein Aufbruch in eine neue Richtung.
Dass man sozusagen sein Engagement für eine andere gesellschaftliche Realität auch kanalisiert ohne Gewalt.
Genau, und sich nicht daran abarbeitet, den anderen zu sagen, das was ihr macht ist scheiße und das dürfte er nicht und das sollte er nicht. Wo man sich bis zum geht nicht mehr daran abarbeiten kann, sondern einfach das eigene Loch anfangen zu buddeln.
Das heißt, man kann letzten Endes auch die Gründung des Chaos Computer Club in dem Zusammenhang sehen.
Unbedingt.
Dass das so eine direkte Folge war. Na super, also jetzt hatten wir ja schon einen schönen Überblick. Fällt euch jetzt noch etwas ein, was wir unbedingt in dem Zusammenhang auch noch erwähnen müssen, was ich jetzt noch nicht so habe ansprechen können? Irgendeine Warnung oder?
Wie das mit der Apoch auch hier in Hamburg weitergegangen ist. Ich habe mich dann in eine total verkorkste Ehe verzogen und dann ganz viel nicht mitgekriegt. Bin dann aber sieben Jahre später wieder aufgewacht aus diesem Albtraum und habe festgestellt, oh, hier gibt es auf einmal das freie Telekommunikationszentrum. Und was die Apoch also mal wollte, NGOs vernetzen, das ist da wirklich materiell geworden, in dem da ein ganzer Rechnerpark an Leitungen lagen, die man in Diskussionen mit der DENIC dann auch sehr günstig kriegte, weil man eben genau in der Zeit auch da angefangen hatte. Und wo weltweit NGOs da einfach die technische Infrastruktur gegeben wurde.
Wann war denn das freie Telekommunikationszentrum?
Das war ein Verein, die hatten Räume hier in Hamburg. Und da standen, als ich da war, so grüßenordnungsmäßig 10, 15 Rechner in irgendwelchen Regalen rum, wie das heute bei Internet-Providern so üblich ist.
19 Zoll-Gehäuse?
Nein, das waren alles so japanesisch-taiwanesische PCs. Und dann waren da ganz viele Datex-P und eine ISDN gab es wohl noch nicht. Ganz viele Datex-P-Leitungen liefen dann da zusammen. Und es wurden Modems betrieben, dass man sich über das Telefon einwählen konnte. Das war wohl die Comlink-Geschichte, genau. Die wieder assoziiert war an die apc.org, die Association for Progressive Communication, was hauptsächlich eine südamerikanische Geschichte wohl war. Und dann irgendwie jetzt vor fünf Jahren oder so ist das FTZ aufgelöst worden als Verein, weil die Mission war erfüllt. Die Telekommunikation ist frei. Ich erinnere mich noch, dass ich hier in Hamburg saß und ich wollte gerne einen E-Mail-Zugang haben. Dann habe ich hier mit der Universität verhandelt. Ich möchte gerne einen Account haben. Dann haben die gedacht und kamen zu dem Schluss, nein, das geht leider nicht, wir haben keine Abrechnungssoftware. Das war dann die Zeit, als man sich per Datex-P in der Uni anwählen konnte und sich international weiter verbinden lassen konnte über so ein schönes, interaktives Mind.
Moment, das war doch schon in den 90er Jahren jetzt.
Nein, das waren die 80er Jahre. Damals gab es in London Kix, da musste ich mir in Kix einen Account holen und dann per Telefon mit meinem 300-Boot-Modell in London anrufen. Deshalb ist das FTZ entstanden.
Welche Rolle spielt dieses FTZ in der Folge?
Das hat eine sehr zielgerichtete Arbeit bei Initiativen gemacht, um den einfachen Know-How-Transfer und technische Infrastruktur zustande zu geben. Und Know-How-Transfer nicht nur über elektronische Kommunikation, sondern auch über Word, wie funktioniert ein Spreadsheet und welchen Drucker man anschließen kann. Eigentlich das, was wir damals im Medienladen gemacht haben, jetzt eben nicht mehr für Videogerümpel, sondern für Rechnergerümpel.
Okay, sonst noch irgendwas anzufügen, würde ich sagen, machen wir einfach mal einen Punkt. Ich bedanke mich irgendwie sehr, dass ihr alle daran teilgenommen habt, an dem Gespräch. Und ja, das war's. Chaosradio Express, Nummer 77. Die Tuwat-Folge, jetzt wissen wir alle mal ein bisschen mehr, warum da ein Komma ist, wo wir eigentlich immer einen Punkt erwartet hätten. Und jetzt wissen wir auch endlich, welche Versionsnummer mal gemeint war. Die von der tatsächlich sträflichen Unwissenheit unserer Computerkonventionen einfach so weggelassen wurde. Ja, und ich hoffe, euch hat das Gespräch gefallen. Wir hören uns sicherlich bald wieder. Das war jetzt erstmal die letzte Ausgabe aus Hamburg für eine Weile, aber sicherlich nicht die allerletzte. Ich komme wieder. Und ja, wie immer, die Bitte um Feedback. Schaut auf unser Blog, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de und könnt euch auch einen Wiki hinterlassen. Oder ihr schickt einfach eine E-Mail at chaosradio.ccc.de Ja, das war's. Viel Spaß noch bei allem, was ihr tut. Bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.